Espie UMC Sony Pictures universe of
Marvel characters Oh
that's doesn't sound as good as MCU but
it'll do the spunk that's all the
commentary on that today we're gonna
watch him the cosmic wonder because I
got hit up by several people directly on
Instagram and Twitter about this leaked
Marvel Wanda vision episode description
Disney Plus I'm telling you several
people contacted me saying you got a
watch cosmic Wonders video this was
yesterday it came out but I was like all
right we'll do it today how's it going
everybody it's Warren welcome back to my
channel the cosmic wonder where we talk
about all things Marvel and of course
everything relating to the MCU today
we're going to be talking about the
Wanda vision series now unfortunately
many of Marvel Studios as current
projects have been put on hold
production for many of the movies and TV
shows that are coming to Disney Plus
have been postponed due to the corona
virus but even though right now there's
no filming going on with all of the
projects at Marvel Studios they're still
managing to do some work like editing
remotely so they are still managing to
work on the one division series remotely
a little bit to keep it as on track as
possible today we have a leak that of
course comes from an anonymous person
who says that they worked on the set and
they've leaked a description on what
they saw from a few episodes on the set
so let's go over what they saw and break
it all down and if you're new be sure to
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and I'm also
starting a weekly giveaways next week so
like with all leaks take this with a
grain of salt we have no way of
notifying if it's true or not it was
posted on for believing it the Avengers
in game + infinity war leaks that ended
up being 100% true were posted
unfortunate as well because it's a place
where you can go and post things
anonymously and if you're somebody who's
working on the set of Marvel Studios
you're gonna want to post it anonymously
so you don't get fired so it could be
true but of course take it with a grain
of salt and also if you are trying to
avoid any and all spoilers here's your
last warning click away now so the
description starts off by saying there
are some really fantastic psychedelic
pictures I worked on several scenes
focusing mainly on the formation of
fractals from the surrounding area
for example the scene where Kathryn Hahn
grabs Wanda from
reality she finds herself in and it was
Brady Bunch's pastel from the 80s and
from the real world which is dark and
chaotic another scene in which kat
dennings dresses as a cleaner and dr.
strange forces her into an astral
projection so she can exit the role she
was Houston the show seems to be half
sitcom and half blockbuster the last
scene was of their living room and of
their kids but everything exploded
seeing many different versions of vision
their children Randall Park Wanda yells
and explodes with different dimensions
and red lights
so there are seemingly three scenes to
break down here
the scene where Kathryn Hahn who is
widely believed to be playing Agatha
Harkness grabs Wanda from a reality a
scene with dr. strange and kat dennings
and a final scene with vision Randall
Park and Wanda exploding and based off
of the tiny little teaser that Marvel
Studios gave us for the one division
series during the Super Bowl and based
off of the other information that we
know about the film we have a pretty
good idea of what's going on here so
let's start with the first scene it's
described as Kathryn Hahn grabbing Wanda
from the reality she finds herself in
and it was a Brady Bunch's pastel from
the 80s and from the real world which is
dark and chaotic so first things we
assumed was going to happen in this film
and is pretty much all but confirmed is
that Wanda is creating different
realities but the key character here is
Agatha Harkness I would be absolutely
shocked if Kathryn Hahn was not playing
Agatha Harkness we even have leaked
photos of her in a witch's costume
now Agatha Harkness is a pretty big deal
not only does she have a major
connection to the Fantastic Four and
Franklin Richards one of the most
powerful mutants that the Marvel
Universe has ever seen she's also
connected to Doctor Doom but she also
trained Wanda and that is most likely
what is happening here in the one
division series and in the comics Agatha
actually does create an alternate
reality for Wanda to help her cope with
the loss of her kids but what's most
likely going on here is that Agatha is
teaching Wanda how to create new
realities because the last time we left
her she was so powerful that she almost
killed fan OHS however we haven't seen
anything that would lead us to believe
that she knows how to create a new
reality so Agatha's main point in this
series is most likely going to be
helping Wanda actually develop which
like powers like
she has in the comics now in the brief
little teaser that we got for the one
division series we did see different
realities take place and this leek
mentions one specifically which is the
Brady Bunch pastel background which we
definitely saw now this reality is a
world to her where vision is still alive
and she has kids but let's jump to the
last scene where it says everything
explodes so it's very possible and
widely expected that Wanda is going to
go a little bit crazy in the show it's
kind of what happened during the House
of M storyline it's a very complicated
story line but to summarize it let's
just say that she kind of goes crazy and
creates this new reality
so right now Wanda is living in this
sort of perfect reality where she has a
husband who is human we know this
because we've seen the promo photo from
Marvel directly of vision being in human
form and in this reality she has two
kids
but sadly eventually she is going to
realize that her kids aren't real vision
isn't real he's not back to life and
this may cause her to have somewhat of a
breakdown and explode as it says here
the last scene is in the living room
because kids but everything exploded and
it says Wanda yells and explodes with
different dimensions and red lights now
the red lights are clearly the energy
that she's going to project we see her
energy all the time and it's always red
but it says that she's going to explode
with different dimensions meaning she
could destroy all of the realities that
she created now when she explodes and
all of the realities that she has
created get destroyed there are two
things that could happen one is simply
that everything that she created and
everything and everyone inside of those
realities when they get destroyed are
completely gone
her kids vision any other characters are
completely gone or they take from the
House of M storyline and some of the
characters that she created in these new
realities her kids her husband vision
come into her main reality this is kind
of what happened in house of
wanda combined two realities and the end
result was some people who were dead
before but were alive in the new reality
oh I can approve marvel
one day we'll create a family vision
will be brought back to life and the two
of them will have kids and these could
come back into the main reality it's
also widely believed that her brother
Quicksilver is going to be returning for
this show as well we have been some
audition scripts leaked for the roles of
the children of Wanda and vision and in
the script it mentions their uncle
well since vision was created by Tony
Stark we know that he doesn't have any
brothers or sisters so the only brother
that Wanda has is Pedro
so clearly while bringing vision back to
life and creating kids for herself in an
alternate reality she brings her brother
back as well which makes perfect sense
why wouldn't she
so when Wanda explodes and always
eventually blow up perhaps Quicksilver
her children and vision will come back
to the main reality with her but then we
have another scene that involves Doctor
Strange and Darci it says kat dennings
who is the actress that plays darcy is
dressed as a cleaner and dr. strange
forces her into an astral projection so
she can exit the role she was Houston
now this is a tiny bit confusing but
here's what I think is happening now kat
dennings has been confirmed to be in the
one division series for a while now but
the question is what role will she play
is she going to be working for shield is
she going to be working for dr. Erik
Selvig still we know that Jimmy woo is
going to be playing a SHIELD agent and
we also know that sword is going to be
around in the one division series as
well so right now her role is kind of
unknown but one thing is for sure based
off of this description of the scene
she's trying to sneak into the sanctum
sanctorum for whatever reason we do not
know but Doctor Strange being the master
of the mystic arts that he is detects
her and sends her into an astral
projection the ancient one did this to
Doctor Strange when he first showed up
and she did it again to the Hulk / Bruce
Banner in Avengers endgame now there's
not much information to go off of here
but it could be assumed that Darcy is
somehow working with Wanda and some
zazic that's working with shield to try
and stop Wanda from exploding and
creating different realities or
affecting the reality that they all
currently live in or somehow she's a
friend of hers but what seems to be
happening here is that Darcy is trying
to look for something that dr. strange
may have possibly a relic that could
help Wanda she could even be working for
Agatha Harkness because
one thing is for sure Wanda is going to
appear in dr. strange in the multiverse
of madness now a lot of us didn't think
that dr. strange would appear in the one
division series but if the series is
going to lead up makes matters it does
make sense yes see very warm energy
creating problems for the multiverse
since she's going to be creating
different realities and based off of the
title multiverse of madness we can tell
that dr. strange is going to have his
hands full with different realities so
what's happening with Wanda in the one
division series is going to directly tie
into and affect dr. strange to now the
one very interesting thing about the one
division series and multiverse of
madness is that in the House of M comic
storyline which seems to play a big part
in the upcoming one division series the
x-men and mutants were very heavily
involved in fact in the storyline Wanda
is so powerful that she says no more
mutants and 90% of the mutant population
is wiped away and we've had many reports
that we could say introduced aversive
madness way to introduce the mutants
they could have settled on possibly
using Wanda and dr. strange to introduce
them there's been a report by Mikey
Sutton that the Illuminati could appear
in multiverse of madness which of course
has several mutants involved there's
also been a report that Namor could
appear in multiverse of madness as well
which is for since we're dealing with
infinite different universes the
possibilities are endless
but based off of these leaked
descriptions of some scenes from the one
division series that we got one thing
seems to be quite clear and that is that
Wanda is clearly going to have a big
impact on dr. strange in the multiverse
of madness and the entire MCU moving
forward whether that's creating mutants
in the future or creating the multiverse
that is going to be blown into madness
by her exploding but let me know what
you think about these scenes that were
leaked we know that vision and Wanda's
kids are going to be in the series but
do you think that they will stay in the
main reality and what role do you think
she's going to play and Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU
for live updates don't forget to follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf Thank You Warren I also wanted
to mention he has a YouTube channel
called superhero central where he just
did a video that's
really really good black widow dark
secrets you don't know about I highly
recommend you guys go check it out if
you're a fan of the cosmic Wonder I'm
sure you'll like that channel as well
considering he runs that one - all right
John kick us off I'm excited to get some
witchy stuff man I like the idea I mean
Kathryn Hahn is not look anywhere near
as old as the characters depicted in the
comics of all the information we found
out that was the most intriguing to me
to me we get Wanda's sensei
so to speak get just more of those which
Eve I've sinned - the MCU on the broader
scale this seems really exciting partly
because it reminded me of kind of like a
legion type show where it's gonna
obviously get very surreal going to
explore a lot of different dimensions
and it just sets up a lot of potential
you know it seems like it's gonna be
very personal tawanda but also like it's
gonna really expand and I like the sound
of getting Doctor Strange and they're
obviously cuz I'm a fan of that side of
the universe this is gonna be
interesting to me because it's gonna
kind of present a new approach to the
budgeting and to the production values
of these things because while I don't
expect the shows to have the same level
as the movies I think they're gonna have
to create some kind of bridge between
them and with as much as these scenes
depict you know pretty is surreal or
pretty like they're talking about
massive explosions and stuff and the
astral realm seems like they're gonna
have to pump a lot of production value
into this these three scenes alone sound
is so different that it scratches my
variety itch so this is a pretty cool
report I didn't for some reason ever
consider the possibility that Doctor
Strange could be appearing in this
series but it would make a lot of sense
considering the fact that Wanda's is
confirmed to be in Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness I don't really
feel like you you need Doctor Strange in
here but then again haven't seen the
show as far as like leaked descriptions
and plots go it's not all that specific
because what we got were like fragments
of scenes described here a lot of waren
kind of hypothesizing or you know
theorizing what this might be
encompassing or what this might be
derived or inspired from one thing
though really stood out to me the cat
Denning side of things yeah she played
Darcy in the Thor movies it's still
unclear what her role will ultimately be
here because while Darcy is obviously
more of a character in the comics and
then she is in the movies himself her
character in the
films was kind of just Funny Cide
scientist character you know friend
would Natalie Portman she wasn't exactly
I don't really know what she provided on
the science side all that well character
it nothing really stood out on that side
she was more there for comedic purposes
and what struck me as a little bit odd
was the amount of focus that are putting
on her and the fact that she was with
dr. strange out of all people in this
reported leak because I never thought of
those two teaming up at me yes I know
he's a medical surgeon dr. mystical arts
and then she is like a scientist but at
the same time I'd never put together the
possibility of those two coming together
in a scene so the idea of them
interacting with one another I feel like
would be a lot of fun just from the
actors standpoint and I had never
thought about Quicksilver actually
getting a chance to come back if
Quicksilver was to return would it just
be an appearance would it be a cameo
would that be an ultimate resurrection
and I feel like that might open up room
for an interesting debate as much as
we've wanted the x-men and the MCU I
think what a lot of people will agree
with me on within the x-men films before
they went over to Marvel Disney was Evan
Peters as Quicksilver was phenomenal I
know that Aaron taylor-johnson steak was
a very like the origin of him is
different he's Russian there's a lot of
different things about that character
I think they have a common is they're
both called Quicksilver and they will
have the Quicksilver abilities or really
the portrayals are a hundred percent
different pretty much every single way
you can fathom I think one thing that we
were all hoping for is that Evan Peters
it still remains this Quicksilver in DMC
you probably not gonna happen
this would make more sense at the same
time I don't feel like Aaron
taylor-johnson properly got his due for
what's to come and as far as the whole
thing with the kids as much as I like
dream imagination exploration and the
idea of watching the psychological
deterioration of wonda occurring where
she believes she's in kind of this Haven
this blissful place that ultimately
destroyed and crumbled beneath her
because it's not a reap it's not her
actual reality for her I would love it
if the kids could come into our MCU
timeline reality well think that there's
always multiverse
is gonna happen it was really make this
a lot easier to follow dimensions and
everything and the and the multiple
story is a timeline that they're opening
up they're gonna have to make that a lot
more clear to follow but as it stands I
don't want it to just be something that
gets lost in the ether with the children
the considering the fact the kids are a
big part of the comics I don't know the
idea of like getting emotionally
invested in something that's ultimately
not real I don't know how I feel about
that I thought they were just kind of
bummed me out and I feel like that
actually just enhanced the whole
experience to make this all that more
powerful if something that she kind of
manifested herself through like
dimension-hopping or whatever be comes
into our reality as well well it seems
like there's a lot you can play there
especially if they do borrow from that
House of M storyline because you know
you could even have your cake and eat it
too by having one to create this one
idea we have cake and eat it too that's
the point of it I may never understood
that phrase yeah I we either had a cake
and not eat it as well I mean why would
you like anytime it's my birthday I
serve myself first plain and simple
you can have your preference and also
not have to compromise because I don't
know I feel like you could have her
create some kind of idyllic reality
where human vision does exist they have
their kids maybe she thinks she's
destroyed it in her big explosion thing
or whatever as the House of M storyline
States releases Warren's recounting of
it states some of those alternate
reality characters make their way into
the actual reality so you know you never
know where that could lead us basically
and I mean as long as we're talking
crazy and as long as there's like is
Tobey Maguire gonna show up in the Sony
part of the universe like who knows
maybe we can have an Evan Peters
appearance and they're in taylor-johnson
appearance it seems like one of vision
is it the most important out of any of
the series we're gonna need to watch it
seems like to keep up especially with
the film's whan division it seems to be
the most integral one introduced an age
of Ultron and having a bit of like
scientific splicing and that's helped
enhance their powers I actually don't
really remember the full details of what
happened in fusing the Kathryn Hahn
Agatha character presumably Agatha I
think that helps lend a little bit more
melding of the sci-fi to supernatural
territory like it's a great way to
transition
by blending it together because from my
recollection with age of Ultron Emily's
in the movie a couple times their
background Quicksilver and wanted a lot
of sci-fi stuff to them and not really
supernatural and then this would start
segwaying us more into a supernatural my
the sci-fi into there alright guys well
Warren held a you guys were encouraging
us to watch this the show does sound
really cool it's my most anticipated one
thing yes from Disney Plus does release
these series we will be reacting them
can't wait subscribe to Warren's channel
the cause of wonder if you haven't done
so already subscribe to superhero
central that's what screw time to us
click a notification valve and last but
not least I wanted to do some name call
out some shout out to some patrons
these are patrons who are pledged for
our takes in bt st if they also get
access to our exclusive patreon lens
story we also like to give them a little
bit of an extra mention here by calling
their names out let's do it james no
Frigga josh philip j smith jr brianna
david's Justin Martin burns reviews
clean the waters melanie weber shifty
claim Jen Smith Ian Sotelo not solely
Darin Kenny waters not related to kill
or die in BG Darth Yoda order 66
Gregory Bullock Ruby Ruby Ruby Ruby IV
or Gomez sa does his Spanish hey guys
thanks so much for pledging to our
patreon page and showing your support to
that little extra tier you guys rock my
socks off and now the video is
officially done
you